hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es einen grund kuchen von
moderat murat weil ich wieder sagt murat
ich möchte einen kuchen backen was soll
ich packen
also es gibt immer leute die sagen sie
möchten ganz flüchtig würdigen kuchen
haben viele mit sahne haben
ich liebe einfach die kombination immer
zwischen schokolade und cover mit ja und
ich hab die schokolade und karamell
mischung noch ergänzt mit einflüssen
obendrauf finde ich sehe einfach optisch
gut aus und macht einfach ein bisschen
krank in der torte also murat hat sich
einen schokokuchen mit karamellsoße
gewinnen oder mit karamell gewünscht und
ich habe gemacht einen schokokuchen mit
karamellsoße und ösen genau unter den er
habe ich viel ist eigentlich auch aus
manchen familien also mein freund zum
beispiel bei dem song bei dem
übernachtet habe klein hat immer morgens
und die mama immer diesen kuchen gemacht
hat und ja sowohl kuchen genau im auge
auf die schnelle und kuchen zum kaffee
gut gab für uns nicht bei uns gab es
kuchen immer nur mittags zur kaffeezeit
jedenfalls ist es in so einer ganz
normal in der guglhupf frauen gebacken
und hat deswegen so eine typische kuchen
frauen die ihnen bekannten auge teams
begrüßen
er kann noch weiter kürzen wir fangen
jetzt schon mal an ich werde zuerst den
rührkuchen herstellen und zeigt euch
damals für den rührteig nehmt ihr 250
gramm butter margarine oder ein
mischfett 250 gramm zucker etwas salz
und vanille extrakt sechs eier einen
espresso 200 gramm mehl ein päckchen
backpulver 40 kakaopulver 200 gramm
butter schokolade und 100 gramm mandeln
jetzt kommt es in eine rührschüssel und
da kommt jetzt gleich der zucker mit
dazu
jetzt auch vanille extrakt und salz
dazugeben und vanille extreme ich immer
ganz gerne weil es eben aus
vanilleschoten besteht ein vanille
konzentrat ist und weil es einfach sehr
geschmacksintensiv ist jetzt werden die
zutaten so etwa 12 minuten cremig
verrührt
sobald ihr zuerst verwursten stelle ich
die maschine auf niedrigste stufe und
gäbe es die eier noch nacheinander ein
sowie das hoch im kurs warten bis das
eifel sind dann erst ins nächste
in der vierten satz kann dies schon mal
die schokolade schmelzen und auf den
mandeln beim malen
als nächstes gehe ich jetzt die flüssige
schokolade mit der zeit
dann kommt jetzt noch für espresso
wieder zu und falls sie jetzt keine
parfüme könnt ihr natürlich auch
weglassen oder ein bisschen milch
dazugeben
aber der ist das ist einfach
unterstützen das schmeckt jetzt den
kaffee nicht sofort raus sondern er
unterstützt einfach das aroma des ganzen
kuchen
so und jetzt kann ich hier noch schnell
die trockenen zutaten vermischen also
kaka mehl und backpulver
jetzt kommen die trockenen zutaten und
auch die mandeln mit zum teil werden
einfach nur kurz eingerückt
der teig ist jetzt fertig und das ist
wirklich ein schöner dunkler tag auch
unterricht auch jetzt sehr aromatisch
jetzt nehme ich eine backform da könnt
ihr jede beliebige backform nehmen die
ihr möchtet ihr so eine kugel umformen
und die hätte ich vorher nie etwas sagt
ramsay und wir waren ein bisschen mehl
mit rein
damit der teig später einfach nicht drin
hängen bleibt und jetzt fühle ich den
teig hier ein
mit den teig ganz leicht verstreichen
und dann ist das schon bereit für den
hof
jetzt wird der kuchen im ofen bei 175
grad ober unterhitze eben vorgeheizten
backofen für etwa 45 bis 50 oder 55
minuten gebacken
ich mache auf jeden fall nach finden und
40 minuten eine stäbchen probe mit dem
zahnstocher und dann hole ich ihn raus
und nach in abkühlen
der kuchen ist abgekühlt ich hatte ihn
übrigens zum abkühlen abgedeckt und
jetzt werde ich eine karamellsoße
herstellen
denn der murat liebt schokolade liebt
karamell und lebt müsse deswegen
vereinen wird die drei kunden in einem
kuchen und ich mache die karamellsoße
zuerst und sag ich mal die zutaten für
die karamellsoße brauche ich 200 gramm
zucker 100 milliliter wasser 300
milliliter sahne eine prise salz 2
esslöffel butter und ich hab ich noch so
eine mischung hier habe ich haselnüsse
macadamia nüsse diesen gesalzen und hier
noch ein paar mandeln hier einmal nur
geschält hier noch gehobelt und hier in
kleinen stückchen als normal erst die
soße dafür gebe ich jetzt den zucker
gemeinsam mit dem wasser in einem topf
und das frühere jetzt miteinander und
lass es dann auf kochen und dann muss
diese mischung so lange kochen bis die
karamell farben wird derzeit kann ich
jetzt schon mal die nüsse vorbereiten
und zwar nehme ich jetzt die nüsse und
haxe ganz grob also ein paar dürfen ganz
bleiben und parma halbieren so dass es
eben eine schöne mischung wird
jetzt gegen ende geht es ziemlich
schnell als ich jetzt nimmt das karamell
so langsam farbe an
und das darf auch gleich nicht zu dunkel
werden da ansonsten der zucker einfach
zu bitter wird es hell karamell fragen
ein paar sekunden
wir sagen jetzt die perfekte farbe
erreicht gefährlich die situation und
die sollte nicht kalt aus dem
kühlschrank sein sondern schon zimmer
waren oder sogar ein bisschen lauwarm
ansonsten habt ihr mich einen großen
platz der sich zwar wieder löst aber
trotzdem ist besser die sanis nicht so
kalt hab ich ein glück mehr glück als
verstand und jetzt lastet ist einfach so
dass ich hin köcheln am best berührt er
ganz sonst verlängert ihr nur oder ich
und jetzt lasse ich die karamellsoße ein
bisschen einkochen bis etwas eingedeckt
ist
die karamellsoße ist jetzt eingedeckt
und ich habe mittlerweile meine top auch
geändert denn der andere doch viel zu
flach und mir leider die soße etwas über
gekocht was aber nicht schlimm war denn
ich habe eine induktionsherd und der
brände zum glück nur dann okay um
ehrlich zu sein ich muss zwei mal über
die qualität zu kleinen der top hatte
aber der hier ist echt perfekt so und so
ist die karamellsoße jetzt auch richtig
gut also von der konsistenz her jetzt
natürlich noch sehr flüssig das ist er
heiß ist sollte auch unbedingt aufpassen
dass wir jetzt nicht rheinland sehr heiß
jetzt mache ich die soße noch fertig mit
einer prise salz die hebräischen
geschmack dadurch schmeckt die soße dann
aber auch nicht zu süß und nicht zu
mächtig jetzt kommt da noch zwei
esslöffel butter mit fallen
und ich kann die soße vom herzen und
einfach ein bisschen abkühlen
die karamellsoße ist jetzt abgekühlt und
ist jetzt auch von der konsistenz her
etwas dicker bis zum abkühlen habe ich
einfach so ein akku kühlkette
untergelegt so und jetzt kommt die soße
auf den kuchen drauf die grosse kammer
schon fertig kaufen gibt sich der
fertige karamellsoße aber es wäre zu
einfach wenn ich gebe mir kann sich eben
auch bestimmen wie die konsistent sein
soll
ok bist du dich genial aus herrschen
jedoch gewünscht häufig einfach den
lippen haben kriegt gleich der ganze
topf der karamellsoße
jetzt nehme ich die nüsse die habe ich
jetzt leicht angeröstet in der pfanne
ohne fett und die lege ich da jetzt noch
drauf
und wer möchte gibt einfach noch ein
bisschen karamell obendrauf
der chor ist jetzt fertig dekoriert und
muratovic sturm wartet schon und möchte
ihnen das hielt gleich probieren der
schweiz saftige
besser ist als ich würde jetzt empfehlen
da du ja ein karamell liebhaber bis ich
mache jetzt einfach noch einen kanal so
drüber oder löffel hat eine lücke ich
kenne wenige die kuchen mit löffel essen
also sie daraus ein bisschen espresso
ich liebte es
also macht es mit parameter auf jeden
fall also wie gesagt man kann ja mehr
karamellsoße darüber geben auch den
kompletten kuchen mit der karamellsoße
passiert aber ich fand es so ist
eigentlich ganz schön wenn man so
business sieht wieder darunter tropfen
mit echte schokolade und wege braucht
nicht lange also der rücken ist ziemlich
schnell gemacht vielleicht eine halbe
stunde zubereitungszeit eine dreiviertel
stunde parkzeit und jetzt noch eine
halbe stunde abkühlt zeiten und sturm
abkühlzeit also innerhalb von
zweieinhalb bis drei stunden ist jetzt
komplett fertig von a bis z
also wie gesagt ich finde karmann
karamell auch fertig kaufen vielleicht
auch da aber so finde ich kann eben
selber auch bestimmen wie die konsistent
sein soll
ich habe jetzt in das auch ein bisschen
heller gehalten weil ich es einfach
nicht bitte haben möchte aber natürlich
auch können könnt ihr das natürlich auch
ein bisschen goldene haben halt jetzt
auch lust bekommen haben auf dieses
rezept geht auf sase - blog.de da steht
es noch mal ganz genau für euch und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß für
nachbacken dir noch einen guten appetit
du sagst stern scheint sowieso nichts
mehr lösen und sie sehen yb drauflegen
zurückfand
für apple ja komm mach deine fotos gehen
wir nicht hin